-Guys, today is Friday and
that's usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
return some emails,
and, of course, I send out
thank you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I was running a bit behind.
I was wondering, can I write out
some thank you notes right now?
Is that okay with you guys?
[ Cheering and applause ]
I appreciate it.
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
Daylight Savings this Sunday,
for kicking off
that special half of the year
when our microwaves are actually
set to the right time.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, yeah!
-I knew it!
-Oh!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Apple,
for releasing a new
yellow iPhone
and basically saying, "Look,
there's only so many cameras
we can slap
on the back of this thing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't know.
It's yellow."
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, au jus,
for sounding like
a really fancy sneeze.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Au jus!
[ Laughter ]
-Gesundheit.
-[ Chuckles ]
Oui oui.
[ Laughter ]
Could you wee-wee
when you had your --
-No.
-No, you couldn't.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ French accent ] No, no.
-That's probably why
it's painful.
-Well, it was weird
because it was European, so.
[You're a-peein']
[ Laughter ]
You know, French.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Korn and Toys"R"Us,
for keeping the backward "R"
industry alive.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Respect.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, light blinking
on my Wi-Fi router,
for either meaning
it's completely broken
or working perfectly.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's blinking.
That's a good thing.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Entenmann's,
for bringing back
the see-through window
on your boxes...
[ Laughter ]
...or, as doughnuts call you,
the red light district.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Mmm!
♪♪
-[ Baritone ]
Donut hole.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, finding the light
switch in the dark,
for letting me get
to third base with the wall.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my Thank You Notes.